hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and today I'm
seeing the new action adventure epic
jeah storm by why what now Geo storm is
a fun movie that's definitely not been
done before let's begin okay yeah so I
went inside geo storm today it's a
disaster film right not not a lot of
marketing behind it because that's what
why would they mean that it's pretty
self-explanatory looking you could
literally not see the film and she would
know what happens it's great I guess
spoilers
I guess so Geo storm is a disaster film
where the world is dealing with a lot of
natural disasters and they make this
man-made satellite station in space that
controls the storms and then once you
know it wouldn't you know it someone
hacks the thing it's called Dutch boy so
I went back to Dutch boy and then they
can control the storms and it's all just
so that they can become presidents
hacking to become president the movie is
just so predictable and so like he's
obviously gonna live like he believes to
go into space and he promises his
daughter that he's gonna get back he's
like I promise you I know I don't stay
upon my promises but I promise you I
will see you again and then she runs off
to her lift and gets in her lift and
goes on her merry way and so of course
you've got it the movie is full of
predictable moments very little dialogue
that's worthwhile there's a few comedic
points that just don't hit it all
because the script is genuinely bad and
genuinely boring and that's fine
whatever kook comedy in an action film
like you don't have to have that it's
kind of become a thing recently where
your action films have to have come I
guess not recently but it's it's very
prevalent now this one tried and it
failed but let's talk about the action
it wasn't good the action is based
around the storms that are happening and
not really the main character so you
don't really see the main characters
going through the action you see
strangers that you have it you don't
know anything about just just dying just
millions of people just dying no one can
do anything to help except for these
like three top people in the government
who can stop this geo storm but guess
what you find out that one of them is
making the geo storm so the action
sucked
also the soundtrack you guys the
soundtrack is garbage every single song
played is that inspirational music when
when they're trying to like reach home
they're trying to like get to your heart
and they play this this music that's
like oh that's not what it is what is it
six hours of epic inspirational music
[Music]
all of it I'm gonna stop it because I
don't want to get taken down for
copyright it's all that every scene they
try to make so important and every line
is trying to be so important in a way
that's like you're just you're just
having a conversation just have a
conversation I believe in you I know
that you can go the distance it's like
okay that's great definitely have those
moments they had some in the ends that
were actually effective and actually
made me feel things but during at the
entire film no oh I didn't think the
acting was particularly good and I don't
think it's the actors fault I think you
get cast in one of these films you say
yes you get paid a lot of money to do
these films I would absolutely say yes
to one of these films and I went tried
to act my crap out but like that's a
term by the way this script just doesn't
lend itself to them doing well and this
started off really poorly for Gerard
Butler who is the lead he's the one who
built dutchboy and he's he's like this
rogue guy the government doesn't really
like him and and and he's just like well
I do what I want because I built ducks
boy but more I'm draw Bubba and that's
just how I talk it's not really but I
tried my best
his brother who I forget his name I've
seen him in stuff I don't even know what
I've seen him in that Beatles movie
everything they said to each other was
you all were fighting because we're
brothers because of course blonde is
just so predictable I did in a way find
it compelling that it set in 2019 so you
know pretty much a year from now crazy
that this year is almost done nuts so
that's weird but it is compelling that
that is where is that just because of
the insanely bad national natural
disaster sorry natural disasters that
we've been having so in a way compelling
but also in another way just like man I
care about the stuff all the time and I
do not want a film that I I paid $17 to
watch this film because it was the only
showing it was early enough to get this
filmed and edited
and it was 3d RPX why am i spending all
this money to see this film that like I
can see in the news sadly so flipping
sadly so that was a weird they got the
timing right in one aspect but in
another just completely wrong you know
what I mean there was a lot of needed
exposition they thought that they needed
to explain everything to you like this
one scientist was like well if this
happens it could cause a Geo storm and
the other characters like oh wow
and he's like a Geo storm that's when
well below a lot happens and then bla
bla bla bla bla happens and that's a geo
storm and it's like oh we get what it's
the title film we don't you often
explain this all to us the script just
it just didn't lend itself to anyone
there's this female black computer
hacker and she was by far the best
character I wanted to be on her side but
the script just didn't lend itself to
make anyone funny or interesting or
compelling or good so she had a couple
funny lines like there's one where it's
like um oh you know this just this feels
like something that you want to do and
then and then you know you might regret
it in the end like Chipotle so like cute
like cute like not cute enough like she
made it cute the script wasn't good then
became this moment you guys and I'm
gonna be real with you I'm not gonna
hide I'm not gonna lie from you right
now life from you right now
I well I kind of got caught up in the
emotions of it at the end which means
that I am so easy to get on to your side
if you make a film and you just do like
the simplest of things to make it good
I'm gonna be all about it I'm game for
whatever so it has to be a really bad
film for me to not be game for it for
the most of the majority of the film so
at the ends they got me they did some
like emotional things and like they set
it up that Gerard Butler's character
died and then they didn't and it was
just really great his daughter got to
see him oh great I love it love
emotional moments like that I loved when
when they make you invested who would
have thought that that would be a good
thing to do there were a couple of lines
calling
out what's kind of happening today I
don't know if they were doing that or if
it was just coincidence feels like they
were trying to call a couple things out
which thank the Lord above because the
film is so directly targeted to what's
happening now whether it was written it
with that intent but it really is it's
about global warming and how they gave
us so many warnings we didn't you know
take their advice and there's a couple
couple fun lines with that the weirdest
parts me I think is that Gerard Butler's
daughter who we see in three scenes is
the narrator of the film so the film
opens up on her voice and then it ends
on her voice and that's so weird to me
all of this happened and it was called a
Geo storm and the one thing to stop it
was this incredible machine and like a
15-minute speech at the end it's
revealed and that machine was built from
one man and that man was my father
so yeah ok so I guess we're gonna like
hang out with this chick wait a lot
we're gonna be uh with her for a while
and and then she's on the post or two
he's like holding her looking back on a
big wave she's like lessons were learned
things were happened you have to live
laugh and love the end it's
word-for-word quote it did not hit like
any marks for me even the parts where I
was invested it was just like oh thank
god I'll take anything so it just it
wasn't good if you like disaster movies
and this is your thing this isn't really
my thing so I'm probably not the one to
speak on this but if you like that kind
of thing I'm like it might be okay I
don't know it just there's so many holes
in the story so many stupid moments
where they're trying to make it so
meaningful
I'll end the month off next week with a
horror film jigsaw I've seen most of the
Saw films so I'm I don't know I don't
know if I'm excited or just just kind of
weirdly interested I think that's the
audience that they're gonna get it's
just like I'm kind of weirdly interested
in this thank you so much for watching
this horror disaster of a disaster film
I'll see y'all
[Music]